My name is Abd Rahman Khal and I am from
Afghanistan. I would like to seek your
guidance on a Christian matter
concerning female who have been
forbidden in some Islamic community.
Take for example Afghanistan
from science education like medical
science, politics and teaching, computer
science and uh as well as employment. So
as you are one of the most respected
highest ranked Islamic scholar in the
era in the era of this world I have
observed that you have not explicitly
addressed this issue. I provided clarity
on it. Islam strongly emphasized and you
uh clearly explained that before that.
So for both men and women and Muslim we
believe that we will be held accountable
before Allah in the given your influence
and
>> brother are you giving a speech here
brother have you come to give a speech
>> no
>> your question should be two or three
sentences
>> so what are your thoughts on such
Islamic community take for example
Afghanistan I sincerely see you will
speak on this matter and provide your
guidance That's it.
>> He's not following the rules and
regulation. He wants others to follow
rules and regulations.
>> Yeah.
>> The brother asked a question but I got
understand talking about Afghanistan
that in Afghanistan
the female education is not permitted.
That's what I understood. So what
guidance to have? I have and he said I
have not spoken. He has not heard me. I
have not spoken. I've spoken a lot.
and I've spoken many times.
I have even spoken personally
to them. What you have to understand
that everything that comes on the media
is not true. Everything that you see in
the media is not true. What the
spokespin the spokesperson of Taliban he
said the situation there in Taliban is
not very safe for the women and as far
as I checked with ambassador of they
have women education all level still
standard six so primary education is
there for all the female only the higher
education because it's the environment
is not safe they are waiting till the
safety is secured that's what they
But for all the other aspects of Islamic
education whether it be Sharia whether
it be Quran whether it be PhD they even
have Sharia teachers etc. They may not
have certain higher education of the
western world. So to say that they don't
have high education is wrong. It's a
misinformation. At the lower level in
standard six they have education for all
girls and boys separately
for the secondary they don't have
facility where they can have female
teachers. So they are waiting for that
for the environment. So if someone
delays the education till they have the
right teacher there is no problem at
all. But the delay should not be too
much. But as far as in the Islamic
field, the Sharia, the Arabic language,
the Quran, when I checked up, yes, they
have ladies even in bachelors, even
masters, even PhD. Hope to answer that
question.